voting in Hong Kong's unofficial
referendum wrapped up on Sunday
organizers are fighting for the right to
choose their leader directly rather than
selecting a candidate from a list
approved by a committee loyal to Beijing
while the result of the ballot will not
be legally binding many believe the
action has symbolic significance this
vote is very meaningful it's an
opportunity for the people of Hong Kong
to exercise their civil rights gay
people Magna Carta chinese state media
have rejected the vote as an illegal
fast under the present system a
committee is responsible for choosing
candidates for Hong Kong's top
leadership position activists say that
limits their choice to Beijing friendly
politicians the former British colony
returned to Chinese rule in nineteen
ninety seven under so called one country
two systems arrangement earlier this
month a policy report said Hong Kong
self-governance was subject to
authorization from Beijing in response
thousands of lawyers took part in a
silent protest occupy central which
organized the vote says it will call
massive protests and paralyze the
financial district if the government
does not agree to reforms